Друзі Ну це знущання після вчорашнього
голосування яким ви зробили перший крок
до того щоб забрати гроші місцевого
самоврядування знищити децентралізацію
зараз говорити про те що от ми тут
хочемо щось допомогти
данищиться децентралізація в країні
нищиться подивіться що відбувається
гроші забирають подивіться що
відбувається Чернігів місто нижче це
місцева самоврядування міська рада в
Чернігові Подивіться на місто Рівне де
також відсторонений міський голова він
може подобатись не подобатись його
обрали мешканці міста на цьому крапка Як
обрали нас з вами громадяни України як
обрали президента України громадяни
України подобається не подобається є
президент є Верховна Рада є міський
голова в Рівному в Чернігові в інших
містах да припиніть вже туди лізти Я не
розумію що пан Єрмак хоче в ручному
порядке керувати розпорядком руху
автобусів в Чернігові чи в Рівному можна
по старій звичці хоче мафи там
розставити до припиняйте це вам що нема
чим зайнятися подивіться в зовнішній
політиці що відбувається радники ірмака
наговорили наплювали вже в бік Індії
Китаю кажуть в них слабкий
інтелектуальний потенціал це судячи до
цього всіх радників Славки
інтелектуальний потенціал що вони таке
несуть тепер розтворилися з Польщею з
головної трибуни світу президент атакує
наших друзів Друзі Ну припиняйте це
займіться своїми повноваженнями наведіть
лад зовнішній політиці там роботи отак
не лізти в місцеве самоврядування Не
забирайте гроші в громад не лізьте в те
в чому не розумієтесь і не маєте цим
взагалі зайнятися
децентралізація - це дуже важлива її ми
маємо зберегти